[Musique]
merci de nous rejoindre pour ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 politique sur tv 78
aujourd'hui nous parlons notamment d'une
élection une élection pour la présidence
des républicains à des yvelines pierre
bédier le président du conseil
départemental est candidat mais tous ne
le soutiennent pas c'est le cas
d'alexandre à dudelange conseillère
régionale qui se présentent également de
l'entendre dans un instant et puis elle
nous reviendrons aussi au compte de
cette édition sur le lancement de la
phase du plan de rénovation urbaine la
nouvelle phase c'est une opération
nationale qui va concerner plusieurs
villes de saint quentin en yvelines en
plateau tout à l'heure alexandra rosetti
vice présidente de l'agglomération en
charge de l'aménagement du territoire
alexandra dimanche
bonjour bonjour et bienvenue vous êtes
conseillère régionale d'ile-de-france
conseillère municipale à sartrouville
également est donc candidate à la
présidence des républicains dans les
yvelines élections internes qui va se
dérouler à la rentrée à 2018 on va
commencer simplement pourquoi cette
candidature déjà mais écoutez c'est vrai
qu'avec othman nasri qui est élu attrape
la région c'est aussi un collègue de la
région nous avons souhaité présenter
cette candidature parce qu'on est parti
d'un constat c'est qu'aux dernières
élections présidentielles 6 % des moins
de 35 ans ont voté pour nous et ça ça
nous désespère et on a envie de mettre
toutes nos énergies au service de cette
fédération pour essayer de proposer de
nouvelles choses et redynamiser cette
fédération pour arrêter l'hémorragie
donner aux français envie de nous
rejoindre et plus particulièrement les
jeunes
il faut préparer la relève il faut
préparer les bases pour que ce parti se
relève demain et puisse gagner les
prochaines échéances électorales pierre
bédier le président du conseil
départemental lui aussi est candidat il
se dit le plus à même de fédérer
l'ensemble des militants des cadres du
parti
les jeunes et moins jeunes ce n'est pas
votre avis mais à écouter en tout cas
nous ce qu'on constate c'est qu'il ya de
plus en plus de personnes qui nous
rejoignent chaque jour on a en a environ
la moitié des délégués de
circonscription enfin la moitié des
dégustations script sion qui sont avec
nous tous les délégués jeunes
du département donc c'est un très bon
signe et puis on engrange tous les jours
donc je pense que voilà on a chacun des
choses à proposer
je pense qu'il faut pas avoir peur du
débat moi j'ai beaucoup d'amitié pour
pierre bédier il n'y a aucun souci
là-dessus
pierre bédier on a la chance dans ce
département d'avoir des grandes figures
de la politique on à gérard larcher
président du sénat valérie pécresse
présidente de la région on à pierre
bédier président du département et donc
tous ces gens là nous ont formés
maintenant on est prêts on est prêt à
prendre la relève et on a envie on a
envie de mettre ce dynamisme au service
de notre parti peut-on parler de fronde
ou pas je vais vous poser la question je
vous laisse et répondrait côté remédier
fusion laisse répond juste après qu'il
vaut mieux faire une équipe parce que le
débat qu'on va ouvrir
il faut faire attention voilà je pense
que nos militants sont encore
convalescents nos jeunes amis eux
pensent qu'il faut affirmer une autre
idée bon c'est selon moi c'est le
principe de la démocratie la démocratie
qui s'expriment
est ce que c'est votre à exactement mais
c'est tout à fait la démocratie et ya
aucun souci c'est pas du tout indécent
d'avoir deux candidats voire trois
d'ailleurs dans une élection je trouve
que c'est moins le signe d'un parti
démocratique moderne où il peut y avoir
du débat des échanges et à la fin tout
le monde sera ensemble bien sûr pour
essayer de relever le parti dans ce
département et au niveau national donc
il faut pas voir ça comme un une fronde
je suis prêt du tout d'accord c'est
plutôt voilà une suscité toutes les
idées les bonnes idées pour pour le
parti des questions sont posées tout de
même sur votre candidature pour évaluer
évoqué par dont tous les tous les sujets
vous êtes candidate ou non suite à une
demande de valérie pécresse en direct on
oppose valérie pécresse à pierre bédier
nous sommes là pour tout dire est ce que
c'est le cas est-ce que c'est pas le cas
alors je ne me sens pas du tout manipulé
par valérie pécresse elle sait que j'ai
mon caractère et de même othman on a
notre indépendance non valérie pécresse
voilà elle s'occupe de sa région et bien
sûr elle a toujours un oeil bienveillant
sur les yvelines et elle s'y intéresse
mais après non pas du tout et encore une
fois ce n'est pas une fronde
envers pierre bédier et moi j'ai
beaucoup d'amis au département enfin
voilà on continue à changer on continue
à travailler ensemble et là dessus il
n'y a pas de souci nous on a juste autre
chose à proposer
et on va en parler mais juste pour
évacuer une dernière fois cette question
il ya un texte ou même qui a été payé
sur les réseaux sociaux signés par des
adhérents des républicains dont vous
soutient ou on peut lire une fédération
n'est pas l'addition de fief politique
administrée par un baron ça s'adresse à
écrire moi je regrettais un peu
justement cette phrase là que je me
plaisais pas vraiment ce que je la
trouve un peu négative
oui c'est pas moi car ce n'est pas moi
qui a écrit cette tribune et bien sûr je
les signe et je l'approuvent
après voilà non je pas envie de rentrer
dans des débats tels que call cette
phrase cette tribune elle est bien plus
longue que cela et donc il ya bien
d'autres propositions dedans voilà
comment on forme nos militants comment
on utilise tous les talents de cette
fédération enfin on est est ce que
voulait dire cette phrase là c'est que
on est habitués à toujours donner la
parole aux mêmes personnes au sein du
parti alors qu'on a énormément de talent
de tous les âges là encore c'est pas les
jeunes contre les vieux pas du tout et
donc il faut mettre plus à profit tous
ces talents que l'on a pour qu'on
réfléchisse ensemble sur l'avenir de dlr
dans les 70 donc l'heure est à
l'apaisement et ensuite le débat
démocratique et ensuite au rassemblement
derrière le ou la présidente de la
fédération pour l'instant le président
c'est à david williams département des
yvelines depuis l'élection législative
et son échec est l'échec plus globale à
des républicains ont il est assez
discret vous le regrettez david douillet
a voulu prendre un peu de recul et je le
comprends ça a été très dur pour tout le
monde enfin on a quand même si là aussi
il faut se faire le bilan on a perdu 11
députés donc ça a été très très dur et
donc je comprends tout à fait qui est un
besoin de recul et donc mais david je
sais est aussi attentif à ce qui se
passe dans le département je nous
l'avons tout de suite en forme et de
notre démarche et donc voilà je suis sûr
qu'il s'investira d'une façon ou d'une
autre dans le futur du parti si on fait
un état des lieux aujourd'hui de votre
formation politique même au delà du
département qui est ce que pour vous
aujourd'hui
les choses vont mieux vont dans le bon
sens avec la désignation d'un nouveau
président au niveau national en vo ket
est-ce que vous adhérez à cette ligne
encore des voix quelquefois un peu un
peu dissonante
alors moi ya plusieurs choses il ya le
discours moi je pense qu'il faut
absolument être une droite responsable
c'est à dire de ne pas être dans la
critique permanente il ya des choses
qu'ils sont votés que l'on aurait tout à
fait pu faire nous même type la réforme
de la sncf donc c'est vrai que j'ai un
peu de mal quand parfois j'entends quand
on aurait pu ne pas voter cette réforme
typiquement je pense aussi et ça le rend
le voc et le fait très bien qu'il ya des
des points où on se distingue nettement
de ce que propose le président de la
république
typiquement tout ce qui s'est passé sur
la csg et la façon dont ont été traitées
nos retraités ce qui se passe sur les
dépenses publiques qui ne laisse
absolument pas alors que le président
impose aux autres collectivités dont la
région on en sait quelque chose avec
valérie pécresse des baisses de
dotations énorme et dans les communes
les communes rurales notamment dont je
m'occupe aussi à la région
c'est catastrophique donc il ya des
vrais points de divergence et il faut
remonter aux français qu' on a une vraie
valeur ajoutée concon se distingue sur
énormément de points mais en même temps
qu'on peut être aussi à une droite
intelligente et moderne qui sait
reconnaître quand les choses vont dans
le bon sens c'est ça qui permettra de
faire rebondir la région il faut être
une droite crédible et c'est ce qu'on
essaye aussi de faire à la région
j'en parle c'est mon exemple régional ou
dans nos communes de la politique par la
preuve on essaie voilà on avance on est
concret et c'est comme ça ces
remontrances là qu'on pourra reconquérir
le coeur des français avec une union
plus large de la droite de l'ensemble
des droites voir des mecs pas du tout
non non je suis absolument pas sur cette
ligne là et j'ai été très choqué par
l'attitude de thierry mariani j'aurais
moi-même aimé qu'il soit exclu du parti
je regrette que ça n'ait pas été le cas
on passe qu'une ya vraiment non je ne
suis complètement contre cette alliance
la moindre alliance avec le fn dont il
faut réaffirmer les valeurs de rêve bien
sûr mais aussi dans le département
entreprises
c'est complètement différent que le fn
on n'est pas du tout sur les mêmes
lignes donc bien sûr qu'il faut
récupérer cet électorat qui est parti au
front national qui pouvait être chez
nous étaient partis au front national et
en restant sur nos valeurs et nos idées
et pas là en allant avec une déviance
précis vous étiez impliqués dans la
campagne de françois fillon aussi vous
avez fait 1 1 point un bilan de cette
campagne au delà des affaires sur ce qui
avait été proposé est ce qu'il ya des
erreurs sur ce qui a été proposé est ce
que il ya des choses qu'on était mal
exprimé parce que moi j'adorais tout à
fait au programme de françois fillon
c'est la raison pour laquelle j'en étais
la porte parole ensuite je pense
malheureusement pendant la campagne on
n'a pas du tout pu en débattre
il ya eu des maladresses c'est certain
il ya certains sujets qui ont été élevés
donc il faut travailler et nous c'est
vraiment ce qu'on veut faire au sein de
cette opération on veut retravailler on
va lancer la toute une série de réunions
thématiques avec des experts pour nous
aider à réfléchir sur ces sujets là et
voir comment en avance sur un projet
pour l'avenir
donc vous allez mener justement pour
terminer cet entretien une campagne de
terrain entre les militants on vous
connaît peut-être moins sur la partie
sud du département c'est vrai mais
othman est bien à lui allait bien donc
on forme une bonne équipe on a toute une
équipe qui représentatif d'ailleurs de
tous les territoires urbains et ruraux
et nord sud
ya pas mal à tout le monde est là et
donc on
aller à la rencontre des militants on a
déjà commencé et là on lance dès la
semaine prochaine et les premières
réunions thématiques
si vous n'êtes pas élu présidente de
cette fédération vous restez aux
républicains évidemment évidemment c'est
lui mais bien sûr on travaillera
ensemble je l'espère en tout cas c'est
ma grande volonté mais jeu comme je
serai élu il y aura pas de cette
question
merci alexandre blanche d'être venu elle
nous parlait de cette candidature je
rappelle que vous êtes comme le
président du conseil départemental
candidate à la présidence présidence
pardon des républicains dans les
yvelines scrutin à d'ici la fin 2010 8
nous poursuivons ce 7,8 politique avec
la fusion annoncée au début du mois
d'avril par les villes de coignières et
de maurepas les maires des deux communes
en tout cas le souhaitent ils veulent
mutualiser les moyens le point avec ce
reportage d'aurélie ronde en ce moment
semble une volonté commune pour un
nouvel ensemble territorial coignières
et maurepas partagent déjà un même code
postal de nombreux projets
intercommunaux archives déchetterie
police municipale un centre aquatique et
bientôt une nouvelle identité
il faut qu'on aille justement dans cette
formidable aventure qui est historique
pour nos habitants et audacieuse en
termes de qualité de service public du
service public on va proposer à nos
habitants c'est à dire de toujours faire
mieux avec nos moyens
une décision partie motivée par la
baisse des dotations de l'état ne
souhaitant pas augmenter les impôts les
maires de coignières et maurepas ont
décidé de s'unir
un mariage qui devrait intervenir le 1er
janvier 2019
depuis 2010 la loi permet en effet aux
communes de regrouper leurs
administrations respectives
actuellement en france il existe cinq
cent cinquante sept communes nouvelles
un nouveau mode de fonctionnement qui
seraient exposés à la population dans
les prochaines semaines il y aura besoin
d'information d'écouté de compréhension
aussi de la population de nos
administrés et donc c'est une phase
d'ici à la fin de l'année et je dirais
même à l'automne d'ici à l'automne c'est
une phase très très importante
on ne fait pas pour nous on le fait pour
les habitants pour garantir une qualité
de service public qui est tant attendu
par nos populations
un projet d'avenir qui donnera lieu à de
nombreux changements un seul maire mais
aussi un nouveau nom pour cette commune
nouvelle
nous aurons besoin d'une votation besoin
de l'avis de la population et il faudra
conserver également l'esprit mort passe
bien mais aussi l'esprit coignières dans
le dot dans le nom de cette nouvelle
commune et ce sera déterminée d'ici
d'ici quelques mois oui dès cette
semaine les habitants de maurepas et
coignières recevront une lettre
explicative sur cette ambition commune
et puis dans le reste de l'actualité
politique des dernières semaines le
lancement de campagnes de la république
en mars pour les européennes le parti et
présidentielle joue gros sur ce scrutin
prévue en 2019
la grande marche pour l'europe
yvelinoise lancée avec une visite de la
maison jean monnet la ministre chargé
des affaires européennes a pu découvrir
la résidence d'un père fondateur de
l'union européenne son salon sa chambre
ou encore des documents officiels
prémices de la création communautaire
mme voyer la méthode monnet rien est
impossible rien on ne s'interdit aucune
idée quand on est face à un péril
en un an on est passé d'un texte un
traité ce qui est très frappant ses
devoirs quand on parle avec les
responsables de la maison jean monnet
que jean monnet travailler en
rencontrant des gens de toutes
catégories socioprofessionnelles de
toutes origines
en les écoutant pour construire ces
projets c'est exactement la même
démarche que la grande marche pour
l'europe
plusieurs militants de la république en
marche ont échangé avec la ministre des
discussions sur les compétences
européennes les défis climatiques et
migratoires ou encore la révolution
numérique
des questions qui devraient revenir
durant la grande marche le point de
départ pour élaborer le projet européen
des élections en 2019 par exemple n'ont
pas là kaminis de lycées professionnels
qui ont été rendues possibles grâce au
soutien de l'union européenne ue s'est
montré qu'elle est dans notre quotidien
est juste sur des aspects de
réglementation parce que c'est souvent
comme ça qu'elle est un peu caricaturé
mais elle est là aussi pour nous
protéger et pour nous faire grandir ce
qu'on souhaite vraiment tirer c'est
d'avoir des réponses concrètes aux
problématiques quotidiennes qui se
posent aux yvelinois yaws yvelinoise
parce que nous pensons que sur des
thématiques comme l'économie comme
l'environnement comme la sécurité
l'europe détient une part de solutions
les marcheurs vont faire du porte à
porte dans plus de 90 communes des
yvelines
une campagne prévue sur cinq semaines
je reçois présent alexandra rosetti
bonjour bienvenue sur ce plateau vous
êtes maire de voisins-le-bretonneux vice
président de saint quentin en yvelines
en charge de l'aménagement du territoire
et nous allons parler justement donnant
rue ce programme de renouvellement
urbain c'est un programme national et
saint quentin en yvelines en bénéficient
aussi des communes de l'agglomération en
bénéficient également un protocole de
préfiguration a été signé avec saint
quentin en yvelines c'était mi avril en
quoi consiste déjà ce protocole alors ce
protocole a été signé pour les villes de
trappes plaisir et la verrière et donc
c'est un protocole en fait qui nous
engage sur des études qui doivent avoir
lieu dès cette année et se poursuivent
en 2019 pour déterminer les axes qui
seront prioritaires
dans ces trois villes tu encore falloir
faire des études avec des choses
concrètes puissent être réalisés en fait
ah oui c'est le passage obligé
effectivement parce que ce sont des
projets d'envergure et donc il est
important de bien cerner là où on va
intervenir
et puis également le protocole est signé
surtout par le pci puisque c'est elle
maintenant qui pilote ce genre de
programme et quels types de réalisations
concrètes on pourrait voir et quel type
de quartier seront concernés sur la
verrière plaisir et trappes et diamants
alors trappe en fait c'est la poursuite
de l'anru 1 donc il ya des quartiers
comme celui du square camus par exemple
qui vont être fortement impacté donc
dans ce genre de quartier on veut avoir
surtout de la démolition reconstruction
comme ça a été le cas par le passé
et puis sur plaisir et sur la verrière
on va être beaucoup sur de la rénovation
énergétique mais également sur le
réaménagement de voirie le
désenclavement du quartier voire
pourquoi pas construction ou rénovation
de gymnases d'écoles voilà donc ce sont
des projets qui impacte la vie d'un
quartier et dont les objectifs sont
vraiment de rétablir de la mixité
sociale plus de 25000 habitants qui
seraient qui seraient concernées qui
pourraient bénéficier de tout ça tout à
fait dont dix sept mille ring pour
trappe pour la commune de trappes très
bien le financement lui aussi forcément
les études n'ayant pas encore eu lieu et
n'est pas n'est pas déterminé on écoute
le directeur général de l'anru à ce
sujet l'intérêt de cette phase de
préfiguration de dire ben on va porter
niveau d'ambition à ce niveau-là et de
discuter si on est capable de
l'accompagner jusqu'où et c'est sur
cette base là que se font les enveloppes
quelles peuvent être les enveloppes
justement il ya un budget minimum
maximum sur tout ça alors aujourd'hui
l'enveloppent c'est un programme d'étude
d'un million 2,5
ensuite c'est ça peut aller très très
loin puisque je crois que tu rappes en
son temps on était monté jusqu'à 360
millions ou 340 millions d'euros en dix
ans donc ce sont des budgets extrêmement
conséquent et dans les financeurs on a
bien sûr l'anru mais également la caisse
des dépôts va également
saint quentin et puis le département la
région et puis bien sûr le principal
contributeur
c'est quand même aussi les bailleurs qui
vont être en charge des démolitions
reconstructions c'est comment va se
passer le travail aujourd'hui
concrètement de cette phase d'étude
ça se fera avec la population sans la
population alors il ya effectivement des
études qui sont d'ailleurs cofinancé par
l'agglomération et par les villes ça a
été votée récemment en conseil
d'agglomération et il ya un fort travail
de concertation a mené parce que
évidemment que la population peut être
inquiété par le quotidien voilà tout à
fait donc je crois que la verrière par
exemple a lancé à une très belle
concertation depuis l'été dernier pour
expliquer aux habitants de quoi ce qui
va se passer et pour surtout les rendre
acteurs de ces changements le mur de le
maire de trappes me racontait que pour
l'anru 1
les gens étaient vraiment vent debout
parce que dès qu'on démolit et qu'on
reconstruit ça peut faire peur et que
maintenant sur la deuxième phase et
c'est plutôt quelque chose qui est
attendue puisque on a vu les bénéfices
dirait du premier programme et quels
seraient le délai pour tout ça entre les
études et les réalisations plus concret
alors sur trois puisque vous dire ça va
commencer dès l'année 2010 9,1 on va
s'attaquer le au square albert camus
en premier et tout en lançant également
la reconstitution de l'offre dans
d'autres villes de saint quentin
puisqu'en fait dans ce protocole il est
prévu la destruction certes de certains
immeubles mais il faut aussi prévoir où
ces logements vont être reconstitués et
encore de la place pour ça il ya encore
de la place
oui bien sûr ben oui puisque toute façon
nous avons des obligations de
construction donc de logements sociaux
en particulier
donc nous profitons je dirais pour nous
en profitons pour permettre la
reconstitution
sachant que la reconstitution ne veut
pas dire relogement qu'est-ce qu'il va
falloir reloger les gens avant même
d'avoir commencé à reconstituer sans
tout ça sur un plan financier les
communes de l'agglomération pourrait pas
réaliser ces rénovations ces
constructions
oui parce que ce sont des coûts
extrêmement important et je crois que le
plan national est un petit peu au
ralenti ces derniers temps il semblerait
que nouveau plan borloo va peut-être
redonner un second souffle à cette idée
mais ce l'est ville et l'agglomération
ne peuvent pas seul supporter des coûts
aussi énorme comme je les ai cité tout à
l'heure néanmoins ça aura un coût pour
l'agglomération tout ça n'est pas grave
cette innovation blanc c'est pas de
l'argent de bétail
non c'est pas gratuit mais en même temps
c'est le notre territoire c'est l'image
de notre territoire
je crois que l'enjeu de l'anru c'est
vraiment de pouvoir améliorer l'image de
de toutes les villes qui sont concernés
assurer une meilleure mixité faire aussi
du développement économique
donc c'est notre intérêt à tous pour
finir d'avoir un territoire qui
continuent à être attractifs il ya eu
des bilans qui ont été organisées sur le
premier dispositif en rue est ce qu'on
aura sur ce second dispositif pour voir
ce qu'il ya deuxième mais sais pas
peut-être y en aura un troisième mais
est ce qui a marché ce qui pourrait être
amélioré encore oui forcément chaque
fois qu'on met autant d'argent sur la
table on fait des bilans donc il y aura
aussi aussi un bilan je pense que c'est
intéressant parce que la ville de
trappes a été pour nous en tout cas sur
saint quentin en yvelines vraiment
pilotes et donc on peut en tirer les
leçons sur ce qui fonctionne ou
fonctionne moins bien aujourd'hui je
pense que le lait les quartiers de
trappes qui ont été traitées montre
vraiment un visage très différent ce
bilan d'étape il n'est pas encore acté
il n'y a pas de date encore sûr surtout
ça là c'est le travail préparatoire qui
va commencer
concrètement les premières réalisations
c'est à des dates à donner je vous ai
dit dans les 19 à la trappe
ensuite peut-être plaisir va peut
avancer un petit peu plus vite aussi
parce qu'ils avaient déjà signé leur
protocole avant qu'on avait déjà signé
un premier protocole avant de rentrer
dans 50 en yvelines notre objectif c'est
que ça avance le plus vite possible
parce que c'est l'intérêt des habitants
merci beaucoup d'être venu en plateau
pour détailler un peu plus ce plan en
rue en rue 2 avant de refermer ce numéro
du 7-8 politique un mot du parti
socialiste qui lui a un nouveau
responsable au début de cette émission
elle nous parlions des républicains qui
doivent se prononcer à la fin de l'année
et bien du côté socialiste c'est jacques
chesnais conseiller municipal
d'opposition à marly et le roi qui a été
désignée écouter le pendant de très
longues années le parti socialiste était
imparti de synthèse
où on trouvait le plus grand
dénominateur commun de façon à
travailler ensemble et travailler
justement
et puis il s'est passé un événement il
ya maintenant quelques années puisque
c'était en 2005 où malheureusement on
est venu un parti où on a fait un
référendum interne vous rappeler c'était
sur l'europe
soi-disant la constitution européenne je
veux dire très clairement j'étais pour
le non
mais ce a divisé le parti profondément
et depuis cette époque là au lieu de
travail et à la synthèse et à convaincre
nos concitoyens des solutions que nous
leur proposions avec elle c'était bonne
pour notre pays on s'est plutôt déchiré
on en paye le prix hollande voilà pour
cet extrait du café politique à
retrouver sur notre site internet c'est
la fin de ce numéro du 7-8 politique à
revoir aussi sur notre site internet on
se retrouve le mois prochain à très
bientôt
[Musique]